juan usado dos tercios de tazas de avena
por porción cuántas tazas de avena
necesita para desayunar 6 porciones hoy
amaneció con mucha hambre
bueno pues cada una de las porciones es
de dos terceras partes de tazas y
queremos seis porciones entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es a estos dos tercios
multiplicarlos por seis y aquí podría
poner unidades a lo mejor aquí podría
poner tazas por porción y aquí porciones
y luego se cancelarían pero bueno lo voy
a dejar así nada más con los puros
números vale bueno entonces tenemos que
hacer esta multiplicación a mí se me
hace más fácil pensarlo como si el 6
también fuera una fracción como si fuera
dos tercios
multiplicado por 6 entre 1 porque así
pues ya simplemente puedo multiplicar
los numeradores 2 por 6 es 12 y luego
multiplicar los denominadores 3 por 1 es
3 entonces quedaría 12 tercios hay otras
formas de hacerlo por ejemplo a lo mejor
podría tomar el 6 y dividirlo entre 3
primero
es decir podría hacer algo de este
estilo mira dos tercios multiplicado por
6 entre 1 lo primero que hago es hacer 6
entre 3
y aquí me quedaría dos y luego sería dos
por dos que sería igual a cuatro aquí me
quedo cuatro y aquí doce tercios pero
doce tercios es lo mismo que cuatro
verdad 12 entre 3 es igual a 4 y estoy
aquí funciona justo porque hacer dos
tercios por seis entre uno
es lo mismo que multiplicar los dos como
le dice aquí arriba pero déjame
escribirlo y dividir aquí este es un 2
dividir entre 3 por 1 y aquí pues
podemos hacer las cosas en el orden que
querramos podemos hacer 6 entre 3
primero para que me quede el 2 2 por dos
es cuatro o multiplicar primero y que me
quede 12 y luego dividir entre 3 creo
que estoy exagerando con tantas
explicaciones para un problema tan
sencillo verdad pero bueno al menos
sirve como un pequeño repaso de de
multiplicación de fracciones vamos ahora
al problema 11 en el problema 11 nos
preguntan cuál expresión representa esto
de aquí a ver
0.00 0.00
0 7 en notación científica
en notación científica bueno pues para
pasar este número bueno los números que
tienen números dígitos después del punto
decimal anotación científica lo que
tenemos que hacer es contar cuántos
dígitos hay poner este número y hacer
este número multiplicado por 10 a la
menos estos dígitos vamos a hacerlo para
que veas a qué me refiero entonces
tenemos tenemos que poner este 7 de acá
primero ponemos el 7 7 por
10 a la aquí va a ir un exponente
negativo porque tenemos números a la
derecha del punto decimal y el exponente
que va aquí es justo cuántos dígitos
tenemos que ya los habíamos contado son
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 x 10 a la menos 7
ok si esto te confundió un poco a lo
mejor te convenga checar unos vídeos que
tengo acerca de notación científica me
parece que son dos o tres y los puedes
encontrar en las listas anteriores ahora
esto fue porque fuimos hacia la derecha
y nos tocó exponente negativo pero a lo
mejor nos hubieran nos pudieron haber
dado el número
siete mil siete mil y si el número
hubiera sido siete mil entonces ahora
estoy recorriendo el punto o estoy más
bien poniendo dígitos a la izquierda del
punto decimal y entonces lo que se hace
ahora es contar todos los dígitos
excepto el primero entonces aquí serían
1 2 3 entonces nos quedaría este 7 que
es este dígito de aquí multiplicado por
10 al cubo sale 123 y este ya no lo
contamos pero bueno otra vez si esto se
te hace un poco raro y quieres saber por
qué funciona te recomiendo ver el vídeo
que tengo hecho por ahí en alguna de las
listas vale bueno vamos ahora al
problema 12
en el problema 12 nos dicen que el
diagrama de ven este de acá muestra el
número de niñas en los equipos de fútbol
y remo en una preparatoria de fútbol y
remo ok aquí tenemos a las niñas que
juegan fútbol acá a las niñas que están
en el equipo de remo y aquí nos marcan 6
este 6 justo quiere decir que son las
niñas que están tanto en el equipo de
fútbol como en el equipo de remo salen
estoy acá
y esta región vamos a ver que nos
preguntan nos preguntan cuántas niñas
están tanto en el equipo de fútbol como
en el de remojar pues eso es justo lo
que te acabo de decir verdad para ver a
las niñas que están en ambos equipos
tenemos que ver cuántas de están en esta
región de aquí si te imaginas tomar una
niña de las que están aquí pues está en
el círculo de fútbol y está en el
círculo de remo y por lo tanto está en
ambos equipos de modo que la respuesta
sería 6 hay 6 niñas tanto en el equipo
de fútbol como en el de remo